as the 2018 election approaches both
parties prepare president Trump takes on
the New York Times and the Muller
blowback continues I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show I hope you had a
wonderful weekend I actually had a
wonderful weekend it was really nice I
got to spend time with my wife and my
kids which is my favorite thing to do
and take cocaine that's not a thing that
I did over the weekend but in any case
let's talk about things that you should
have done over the weekend but you
didn't okay like get new blinds for your
apartment the fact is look at those
blinds
those things are hideous look at the
place you live care enough to live like
it's a pigsty go out and get some nice
blinds okay you don't think about your
blinds very often because why would you
but when you actually look at them you
realize that you need an upgrade and
that's where blinds calm comes in so go
check them out
right now they make it really easy for
you to replace those blinds not sure
what you want even where to start with
blinds calm you get a free online design
consultation just in the pictures of
your home they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what's gonna work with your color scheme
your furniture and specific rooms they
will even send you free samples to make
sure everything looks as good in person
as it does online every order gets free
shipping and this is the best part if
you screw it up lines comm will remake
your blinds for free if you accidentally
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll make it for though they'll redo
it for you it's it's just amazing okay
there's no reason for your place to look
like a trash heap instead go over to
blinds comm and get it fixed 20% off
everything right now at blinds comm when
you use promo code Ben that's blinds
comm promo code Ben for 20% off
everything has the faux wood lines the
cellular shades the roller shades and
more blinds calm promo code Ben rules
and restrictions apply they're awesome
we've used them for our own home I vouch
for their their customer service is
really terrific go check it out
blinds.com promo code banner alright so
it was a busy weekend not only for me
but for Rudolph Jae Giuliani I don't
actually know his middle initial list
but in any case Rudy Giuliani former
mayor of New York he is now president
Trump's personal attorney and he was on
national television over the weekend and
on Monday morning talking about the
President of the United States and
Michael Kahn now as you recall when last
we left our compelling narrative Michael
Kahn the president's other former
personal attorney he had been arrested
well not really arrested but raided by
the FBI the FBI had gone into his office
they'd found all sorts of recordings and
then Michael Kahn had begun to sing like
a bird in the press he had gone out
there and suggested that the President
of the United States had in fact paid
off a bunch of women he
tapes to prove it and then he suggested
that President Trump knew about a 2016
June 2016 meeting between Donald Trump
jr. and members of the Trump campaign
and this woman in Natalya vessel nets
kya who is a Russian hired lawyer who
was supposed to be a go-between
supposedly between the Russian
government and the Trump campaign and
Cohen says Trump knew about this now he
has no tapes to prove it but we're
supposed to believe Michael Cohen anyway
which would be fine except that Michael
Cohen is a pathological liar but so is
everybody else apparently like this is
the problem with politics pretty much
everybody's a pathological liar so who
do you believe and the answer is you
really shouldn't believe anybody but I
will say that Rudy Giuliani is in an
awkward position because now he's the
president's personal attorney on the
mulher investigation and the Cohen
matters and Giuliani has two jobs one is
to try and exonerate his man right to
make sure the president Trump doesn't
get in trouble they doäôt not be in and
two is to perform for president Trump
and that's not the easiest job because
President Trump likes performative
people he elects people who go out there
and do these kind of loyalty shows on
national TV we know this about President
Trump he's he's a guy who enjoys the
visual and so there's been true since
the beginning of his administration
people in his administration say and
have said that when they once he talked
to President Trump what they try to do
is go on national TV on a show they know
he is watching and then talk to him that
way because he likes to watch the telly
so Rudy Giuliani was on the telly and he
was talking about Michael Kohn and what
he had to say about Michael Kohn it may
be good it may be entertaining for
president Trump but it's not great for
public relations if you're trying to
make sure that your client looks
innocent you probably shouldn't say
stuff like this turned out to have a
close friend betray him like like Iago
betrayed a cello and Brutus put the last
knife in the season okay she's going to
full Shakespeare references right there
Iago betraying Othello and Brutus taking
the last knife Caesar there a couple of
problems with this particular analogy
one Iago succeeded in destroying Othello
and also Brutus succeeded in killing
Caesar so if he's if he's likening Rocco
and Brutus to Michael Kohn what he's
basically saying is Michael Cohen's
gonna take down the President of the
United States well that's not so great
also just this kind of vitriolic back
and forth is not useful like having your
lawyer out there saying listen Michael
Kohn has a long history of dishonesty
Michael Cohen
has described himself as loyal to the
presidents as the president's bagman and
all this routine and the media hated him
and thought he was dishonest until he
flipped and all the sudden you guys
think he's honest as the day is long all
that would be fine but the Shakespearean
reference is probably not good and then
Rudy Giuliani goes even further and this
is where he gets himself in real hot
water he's talking about President Trump
not colluding with the Russians and then
he drops this line
he was never involved in intimate
business relationship with Donald Trump
never that's just four months they're
not gonna be polluting about Russians
which I'm not even know if that's a
crime colluding about Russians okay you
start you start analyzing the crime the
hacking is the crime the present impact
course not that's the originator
bragging okay so the the goal posts are
now moving and then it's very difficult
to see the to see this playing well in
in the public sphere because when you
got your personal lawyer going out there
and the goalposts moved from he didn't
collude to even if he did collude it's
not a crime people start to think well
did he or didn't he like me here's the
thing
Giuliani isn't wrong okay I've gone
through the statutes with regard to
collusion okay there's no there's no
actual statute on collusion there are
statutes about conspiracy there's
a-there statutes about campaign finance
violations then all sorts of statutes
that could be implicated if the
presidents of the United States was in
fact colluding with the Russians in
order to shift the results of the 2016
election right there are actual statutes
that are on point but they don't talk
about collusion they talk about a
variety of other specific crimes
collusion is a blanket umbrella term
that is supposed to cover a wide variety
of activities so when Giuliani says
collusion itself isn't a crime this is
technically true however the question is
not that the question is is it
impeachable okay is it something where
the American people turn on the
President of the United States and say
you are guilty of trying to interfere
with the election by working with the
Russians to do so doesn't matter where
there's a criminal trial the real
question is whether the American people
decide that they are so sick of all of
this that they asked Trump in 2020 or
they asked Republicans in 2018 and then
an impeachment takes place right so when
Giuliani says this sort of stuff it's
just not useful now I'm somebody who
doesn't believe the President of the
United States colluded with the Russians
I don't think that's a thing I don't see
any evidence so far and the President of
the United States was working with the
Russians and they were coordinating
their activities and that these
coordinated active
exchanges of information played any part
in the actual election cycle itself so
again I don't see why Rudy Giuliani's
moving on this point but unfortunately
he's not the only person in Trump's camp
who's saying this sort of thing
chris Christie this morning came out and
said exactly the same thing he's on
national TV and Christie said the same
thing he said I'm not sure collusion is
a crime don't shift the goalposts
publicly if the goalposts like just as a
lawyer okay putting on my lawyer hat if
I'm arguing for my client my first
argument from our clients is my client
is innocent and then if it turns out
that my client is guilty of something my
second line of defense is even if my
client is guilty of that it's not a real
crime but I don't preemptively go to my
second defense I don't preemptively go
to well I'm not sure collusion is a
crime because this is all a public
relations battle and this is what has
bogged down the Trump administration not
the actual criminal proceedings the
actual criminal proceedings take time
they take money all of the hearings all
the interviews all that stuff is
expensive and all that stuff is annoying
but that's not really what's bogged down
the administration what's bogged down
the administration is this perception
that President Trump is is guilty of
something now most Americans don't
actually believe that President Trump is
guilty of something which is why it's
weird that Rudy Giuliani is is out there
saying that collusion is not a crime
it's just it's a it's a huge unforced
error by Rudy Giuliani and it doesn't
help when the president is tweeting
about robert muller so president Trump
continues to tweet about Muller and here
is what he tweeted over the weekend he
tweeted there is no collusion the Robert
Muller rigs witch-hunts headed now by 17
increased from 13 including the Obama
White House lawyer angry Democrats was
started by fraudulent hace a paid for by
crooked Hillary in the DNC therefore the
witch-hunt is an illegal scam okay then
here's the thing some of what he's
saying here is true okay this idea that
the this idea that the Muller
investigation was at least partially
reliant on a dossier funded by Hillary
Clinton that's true
but I don't know what the point of this
is other than to to sound off now listen
Republicans believe President Trump I
think most Americans are relatively I
would say skeptical of the mother
investigation I think rightfully so but
I'm not sure that at this point the
president's constant focus on this thing
is helping
he also tweeted out his Robert Miller
ever going to release his conflicts of
interest with respect to president Trump
including the fact that we had a very
nasty and contentious business relation
I turned him down to head the FBI one
day before appointment as SC a special
counsel and Comey is his close friend
also Weissmuller only appointing angry
democrats some of whom have worked for
crooked Hillary others including himself
worked for Obama and why isn't Muller
looking at all of the criminal activity
and real Russian collusion on the
Democratic side Podesta dossier I think
there's some actual real good questions
to be asked about the Muller
investigation and why they've not for
example looked into Podesta or if they
have how much they have and if they've
looked into the dossier how much they
have done that but remember every
Republican including Newt Gingrich was
out there saying that Muller was honest
an honest man and now Trump is out there
slamming Muller the question is does
this make Trump look more innocent or
doesn't make him look more guilty now
people who already believe he's innocent
are gonna say it makes them look more
innocent because he's an outraged man
okay fair enough but for the vast
moderate undecided in the middle do you
really think that they look at tweets
like this and Rudy Giuliani's statement
and say this sounds like a guy who's
being wrongly maligned or do they look
at that stuff and say well maybe there's
something to this again I'm saying this
is someone who believes there is not
something to this or at least the
evidence has not been shown that there
is something to this yet this is what I
find so confusing I'm not I'm not sure I
understand the public relations strategy
on all of this and the Republicans are
getting involved in this too it's not
just Trump and the Trump administration
Devin Nunes who's the who's the House
Committee Chairman for intelligence he
came forward and he says that the DOJ
and the FBI been stalling turning over
their documents because they hope the
GOP will lose the midterms and then they
won't have to turn over those documents
so he's going after the DOJ and the FBI
here is Devin Nunez from from California
there's a stall game going on at DOJ and
FBI they're trying to stall as much as
they can hoping and betting that
Republicans would lose the house in the
fall okay so and there's this is all fun
there's only one problem with it and
that is if the president wants to
declassify this stuff you can declassify
this stuff now if it's true there's this
awful conspiracy going on inside the DOJ
inside the FBI and the President of the
United States has an obligation an
obligation does he classify all of this
material so we can see what is actually
going on here it's not enough to sit
there and complain about rod Rosenstein
and attorney general sessions and and
and the and the head of the FBI right
it's not it's not enough to do that is
it because first of all Trump appointed
all those people
so if you're really upset about this
stuff then Trump's ought to be tweeting
less and declassifying more if we really
want to get past all this tweet less
declassify more this is my advice you
know the president doesn't have to take
it he's obviously done well not taking
my advice before but I do think that it
would behoove him to recognize that the
the base that brought him here is not
going to be enough to win reelection or
necessarily to do well in the 2018
midterm elections okay before I continue
along these lines and I want to talk
about President Trump versus the media I
want to talk about the the incipient
government shutdown but we'll talk first
about the fact that you need to make a
resume better okay the reality is the
economy is doing really well right now
so that means that there are lots of
opportunities out there for you well if
there are lots of opportunities you need
to be making your resume constantly
better and that's where Skillshare comes
in it's an online learning platform with
over 20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
in social media marketing and
illustration data science mobile
photography creative writing you name it
they've got it and whether you're trying
to deepen your professional skill set or
start a side hustle or just explore that
new passion skill share is there to keep
you learning and thriving we here at the
office have used skill share for a
variety of classes I've used it for
social media marketing as well as for
watercolours because I need to relax
sometimes guys and that's what skill
share can do for you again they have all
these experts these classes are like 45
minutes and they really are first-rate
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today well the
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for just 99
cents again Skillshare is offering ben
shapiro show listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro at
Skillshare comm slash up hero you can
start your two months right now skills
shared comm slash up here I'll go check
it out
it's a lot of fun to end you're gonna be
learning and making your resume better
which means you're gonna get paid more
down the line with these additional
skills skills shared comm slash capiro
go check it out right now okay so the
president is obviously very focused on
the Muller investigation which i think
is a waste of effort I think it's a
waste of effort the mother investigation
is going to do what the mother
investigation is going to do the
president's is not going to fire robert
muller the republicans are not going to
impeach rod Rosenstein it's a lot of
sound and fury signifying nothing and in
the end I don't think that Muller is
gonna come up with anything anyway what
I really think is going on here you know
there are a lot of people who say okay
so then why is Trump so fussy about this
if there's nothing happening why is from
so upset well
you'd be upset too if somebody suggested
that your election victory was not real
and that it had been achieved by
colluding with a foreign power but all
of that said the president really is not
doing himself any service with his great
frustration a lot of a lot of the
president's mistakes have been made out
of a sense of frustration and there's no
reason you should feel frustrated right
now the economy is doing really well
he's doing finding the approval ratings
all he ought to be doing is focusing on
what is the program for 2018 and beyond
because the polls right now are not
looking good for the Republicans in 2018
so how's it gonna turn this thing around
well it's just a few months to go here
right now there were two polls last week
that came out D plus 12 in the generic
congressional ballot okay that has to do
the president has to assert some
leadership on all this it was funny over
the weekend there's a story about Barack
Obama and Michelle Obama who are
apparently in Europe partying at a jay-z
Beyonce concert dancing at jay-z Beyonce
concert and Jake Tapper of CNN got in
all sorts of hot water with the
left-wing because he suggested that well
Obama and spouse are partying the
Democrats are at low ebb the lowest ebb
they've been since the 1920s which is
true so why is he partying it up the
same thing could be said right now for
the president stop focusing so much on
Muller it's time for you to focus on how
exactly you achieve victory in 2018
midterms because if you lose the house
and you lose the Senate not only is
nothing gonna get done in 2018 to 2020
there will be nothing but endless
investigations against you nothing but
endless investigations against
Republicans against Trump himself
against other members of the
administration I mean you want to ensure
that you lose in 2020 an easy way to do
that is by not doing enough to win in
2018 2018 is gonna have a major impact
on 2020 right now the Republicans can
play rearguard for president Trump the
Republicans can stop President Trump
from doing some of the things that would
damage his own administration the
Republicans in the house can sort of act
as a as a back shield for the president
but they can't act as a deflector shield
for the president if they're in the
minority well with all of that said
let's talk about how the President of
the United States is going to attempt to
affect the midterms so president Trump
has a strategy his strategy for the
midterms is this he is going to go full
on immigration and attacking the media
this is his strategy so he's not gonna
pump up the economy at the economy some
he'll he may talk about the Democratic
agenda a little bit but mostly he is
going to be talking about I think
immigration and the media which is the
gal that brung him let's be real about
President Trump in 2016 his campaign if
it was won on any two issues it was you
hate the media and the Democrats are
softened emigration those were his two
big issues during the campaign okay so
president Trump tweets out on Sunday
about the government shutdown about a
government shutdown he says when the
media driven insane by their trump
derangement syndrome reveals internal
deliberations of our government it truly
puts the lives of many not just
journalist at risk very unpatriotic
freedom of the press also comes with the
responsibility to report the news and
then he continues along these lines this
is accurately 90% of media coverage my
administration is negative despite the
tremendously positive results we are
achieving it is no surprise the
confidence in the media has at an
all-time low I will not allow our great
country to be sold out by anti Trump
haters in the media in the dying
newspaper industry no matter how much
they try to distract and cover it up our
country is making great progress under
my leadership and I will never stop
fighting for the American people as an
example the failing New York Times and
the American and the Amazon Washington
Post do nothing but write bad stories
even on very positive achievements and
they will never change the president is
ripping on the media and he hopes that
this is going to get Republicans out to
vote now I don't think this is a
terrible strategy I'll be real with you
I don't think this is the worst strategy
President Trump has ever come up with I
think that there are some effectiveness
to this the reality is that the polls
show that Republicans hate the media far
more than they hate pretty much anybody
else in American life there is a morning
console poll that came out over the
weekend and what it showed is who do you
trust more right here's the question who
do you trust more the national media or
president Trump's White House
Republicans 71% say president Trump's
White House only 7% say the media 22%
say they have no opinion that is a
slight shift in favor of President Trump
since the same time last year
independents say that they don't trust
the media this is that this is the
fascinating part when you think that
President Trump is destroying the media
the media are destroying the media how
do you know this look at the numbers
among independents so yes Republicans
have shifted dramatically in the
direction of the White House as opposed
to the media but look at the numbers on
Independence in May 2017 26% of
independents said that he believed the
president from more than they believe
the media 35% said they believe the
media more than president Trump 39% said
they didn't know a year later 24% said
they trust president Trump's that's a
decrease of 2%
2% said they trusted the the media which
is a decrease of 3% and 44% said they
didn't know who to trust which means
that while the media say you should you
ought to trust us and Trump says you
ought to disregard the media most people
are saying I don't trust either you
folks at least and Grant and then the
vast majority of people in the middle
they say I don't I don't really trust
any of you people and even among
Democrats you're seeing that right even
among Democrats are saying that fewer
people trust the media now than they do
a year ago only 7% of Democrats say they
trust president from more than they
trust media 63 percent say they trust
the media more than they trust Trump but
that number was 66 percent last year and
29 percent say that they don't know who
to trust which means that more people
believe that the media are simply not
credible which demonstrates the poor job
that the media have done in staving off
president Trump's correct critique of
the media that they are wildly biased
against him now President Trump tweets
out that all of these outlets are biased
against him and he calls them the enemy
the people and all of this drove pinched
souls burgers son right in the new souls
burger who runs the New York Times - to
put out a statement about his meeting
with the president so according to the
New York Times President Donald Trump
and the publisher of the New York Times
AG Souls burger engaged in a fierce
public clash Sunday over Trump's threats
against journalism after souls burger
said the president misrepresented a
private meeting and Trump accused the
times in other papers are putting lives
at risk with irresponsible reporting
Trump said on Twitter that he and Souls
burger had discussed the vast amounts of
fake news being put out by the media and
how that make news has morphed into the
phrase the enemy of the people sad and
then souls burger put out a statement he
said he had accepted Trump's invitation
for the July 20th meeting mainly to
raise his concerns about the president's
deeply troubling anti press rhetoric he
said I told the president directly I
thought his language was not just
divisive but increasingly dangerous is
what Seoul's burger said I told him that
although the phrase fake news is untrue
and harmful and far more concerned about
his labeling journalists the enemy of
the people
I warned this inflammatory language is
contributing to a rise in threats
against journalists and will lead to
violence and I said months and months
and months ago if the media actually
wants to regain credibility the best way
to do this is to turn down the rhetoric
- - and turn up the fact-checking 2:10
that's the best way to do this instead
the media have turned up the rhetoric
all the way to 11 and then turn the
fact-checking down to about 4 they're
spending most of their time showing that
they enjoy being in this sort of Rock'em
Sock'em robots mode with the President
of the United States what does that mean
really neither of them is winning but if
neither of them is winning frump is
winning because the media rely on trust
president Trump's a politician he
doesn't rely on trust
president Trump relies on policy and
policy wins the media rely solely on
trust if you trust Trump great but if
you don't trust the media terrible for
the media okay so in just a second I
want to talk about the other prong of
president Trump's 2018 plan prong number
one is attacking the media prong number
two is immigration we'll talk about that
in just a second first let's talk about
you put them let's talk about that face
hey sun spots brown spots discoloration
red and flame patches all of these could
be gone with the brand new gen you sell
sun spot corrector Ella from Rockford
Illinois right says I have both age and
acne spots and this stuff is actually
fading both of them the serum is worth
every penny ladies and gents the Gen you
sell sunspot corrector is here it is
yours free just for trying gen you sell
today it's a must after your summer
finally see those stubborn sunspots
vanish and the bags and puffiness those
are gone two and four results in less
than 12 hours the Gen you sell immediate
effects is also yours for free light
clean effective natural skin care that
gives you amazing results healthier
softer skin day after day no one does it
better than sham Inigo to Gen you sell
calm right now or call 866 324 95 that's
gen you sell calm right now eight
hundred six six three twenty four ninety
five my wife my mom they both use gen
yourself and the incredible results are
obvious to them obvious to me as well
you be the judge you'll see the magic of
Shama neat or you get a hundred percent
your money back so it's risk-free eight
hundred six six three twenty four ninety
five or go to Gen you sell calm that's
eight hundred six six three twenty four
ninety five or you go to Gen you sell
calm again Jen you sell calm and it
really is it's it's terrific stuff so go
check it out okay so prong number one of
president Trump's 2018 plan is attack
the media that will get his base fired
up I'm not sure it's gonna get them
fired up enough to actually go out to
the polls in massive numbers Pro number
two is immigration and here the
president has it right the president
knows that his base is deeply concerned
about the impact of illegal immigration
the president ran on building the wall
there is no wall and Coulter pretty much
every day tweets out that we are now in
day whatever it is four hundred of the
presidency and not one foot of wall has
been built by the President of the
United States she's very frustrated with
that so the president now says okay now
is the time I'm gonna go for a
government shutdown he tweets out on on
Sunday quote I'd be willing to shut down
government if the Democrats do not give
us the votes for border security which
includes the
I must get rid of lottery catch and
release etcetera and finally go to
system of immigration based on merit we
need great people coming into our
country now is this a great strategy
probably not to say it out loud
would he be right to shut down the
government meaning he's not gonna sign
any bill that doesn't include border
funding yeah I think that he'd be fully
within his rights to do that I think
he'd be fully within his rights to do
that I think the president ought to do
that a lot more often
he's been signing in trillion dollar
budget packages for the past year and
those packages are garbage those
packages are giant pork laden barrels of
crap the President of the United States
should exercise that veto pen and if
Mitch McConnell and the Republicans
can't get it done well they can't get it
done but the president is fully
justified in saying listen I want the
porter funding or I'm not going to sign
this now should he be openly talking
about I'm willing to do government
shutdown probably not what he really
should be saying is listen I know the
kind of bill I want to sign and
Democrats it's their choice whether this
shut it down or not this is what Obama
did and did successfully now Obama of
course had the help of that compliant
media doing his work for him but the
first person to say shut down is usually
the person who is blamed for the
shutdown so that is not particularly a
great political tactic but is it smart
for the president to stand on this
particular soapbox yeah I do think that
this is a it's smart for understand on
this particular soapbox now the problem
is he's not gonna get what he wants
because the Republicans are not gonna
pass a bill along these lines and the
Democrats are not gonna pass a bill
along these lines so the question
becomes if the president is going to
declare a game of chicken is he actually
gonna put a brick on the accelerator now
one of the things that you do in
politics to do a tiny bit of game theory
there is a there's a game in in game
theory called chicken now they get the
game of chicken you'll recall from
things like rebel without a cause you
see it in movies sometimes two people
basically drive cars directly at each
other and the question is who's going to
turn the wheel first whoever turns the
wheel first is considered the chicken
and loses the game well the way that you
win that game if you are that interest
in winning is you take a brick you put
it on the accelerator and then you move
over into the passenger seat right
because you've now demonstrated to the
other guy I am not turning no matter
what but no matter what you do I can't i
pre committed I cannot turn well the
president if he's in an eclair game of
chicken he has to pre-commit and that
means that he has to say listen I will
veto any bill that doesn't include this
provision right here and then we find
out whether the other side is
blink or not he hasn't done that in the
past he said in the past that he's been
willing to do a government shutdown he
hasn't actually been willing to do a
government shutdown and blinking is not
a particularly successful strategy
Democrats are pre committing they're
saying we're not gonna be bullied so
here's Maxine Waters aunty Maxine as
they call her saying that she's not
going to be bullied into giving the
president the funding necessary in order
to protect our border this president is
a bully and he'll try and intimidate all
of us he's not going to shut down
anything American citizens are not gonna
pay for this wall he's not gonna shut
down the government and we're not going
to be intimidated by his bluffing and
his bullying okay I do appreciate that
aunty Maxine a woman who suggested that
people be confronted in gas station
parking lots and she's hauling President
Trump a bully so that's great but she's
not wrong that if you're going to play
this game of cars if you're gonna play
chicken you got a pre-commit so if the
president wants to shut down the
government or if he'd rather if he wants
to get what he wants in this bill then
he needs to say here's what I will veto
and he needs to make clear what he will
veto now it's pretty clear the
Republicans don't believe him and this
is the problem right so Senator Ron
Johnson who was elected as part of the
tea party he says listen all of this is
not particularly helpful this shutdown
threat stuff I certainly don't like
playing a shutdown politics and how
damaging would that be for Republicans
ahead of the November races I don't
think it'd be helpful so let's try and
avoid it okay so Republicans in Congress
are very much afraid of the possibility
of a shutdown but I'm not sure why they
should be and I said this with regards
to the last threat by President Trump of
a shutdown I don't know that they should
be that scared because in essence it's
the people who are seen as obstructing
the government's workings who are going
to be blamed for any sort of government
shutdown and Republicans will get out to
the polls for this sort of stuff
Republicans will get out to the polls I
you know there was a lot of talk after
Ted Cruz was quote-unquote responsible
for a government shutdown back in 2030
and this was going to damage Republicans
Republicans won walking away in 2014 all
this talk about government shutdowns
damaging the damaging the Republicans I
just I haven't seen that that's really
been true in general so if President
Trump wants to do it then I say go for
it
I just wouldn't signal that you want a
government shutdown I think the way you
should say is listen here's what I'm
willing to veto and here's what I'm not
willing to veto but you know I think
that I think that the idea of
immigration and media being the two
prongs for 2018 are not actually that
bad the other prong
obviously has to be the insanity of the
left and why these people should never
be in charge of anything
the latest reason is because of this
there's a new study out today with
regards to Medicare for all okay so this
has been the the call from insane nutjob
Bernie Sanders so Bernie Sanders when he
is not stuffing his faith with pudding
believes that we ought to have Medicare
for all Medicare is basically a blanket
coverage for people who are old but he
wants that now applied to everyone he
essentially wants a government
nationalized health care system he says
that this will pay for everything it'll
it'll pay for itself whatever he has
asked people who asked him so how do you
pay for this Bernie is that's not
important what's important is that
Europe finds a way to pay for all of
this and Europe has fantastic health
care okay first of all the Arab has 60
65 % tax rates these health care systems
are bankrupting countries and the fact
is that they've had cutbacks in a lot of
these areas they've had to bring in
immigrants too to simply staff the
medical profession in places like the
National Health Service in Great Britain
they're there these are all much smaller
countries to me when you talked about
Norway or Denmark these are places that
have a population less than the
population of LA County alone and
homogenous and engaged in the same
culture and you know it's a lot e let's
put it this way it's it's it's not easy
to scale a nationalized health care
system to a system of 300 'no Slevin
forget about the the fact that it is an
invasion of people's rights and then
it's not my job to pay for your health
care because your health care is yours
it's my job to pay for my health care my
kids health care my family's health care
it's my job to help out with people who
i want to help out with regard to
charity but it is not my job to pay for
your health care because if i'm paying
for your health care that creates a
perverse incentive system where you can
go make a bunch of decisions that are
not great for your health knowing
somebody else is gonna pick up the tab
and access health services at a faster
pace all of that said the effectiveness
of these healthcare systems abroad there
are a bunch of different types of
systems everybody sort of thinks that
there are two systems there's the free
market system and then there's the
nationalized system this is not true
there are a bunch of different types of
system the Swiss system is a lot more
privatized than for example the Nordic
system the Swiss system works great in
the neuro system works pretty well too
there are differences between how they
work they both work but part of the
reason they both work is because they
had functioning healthcare systems
before they actually had a nationalized
healthcare system in Sweden for example
or in Norway and the reason
for that is again because lifestyle
differences and cultural differences in
these places these are not the same
places as the United States you have to
take these things into account you can't
just take something that works in
Denmark and assume it's gonna work in
the United States that's idiotic that's
not how policy actually operates anyway
Bernie Sanders says he wants Medicare
for also there's a new study out today
from the Mercatus Center at George Mason
University in Virginia now the left is
saying that this this is just this study
is nonsense it's nonsense how do we know
that it's nonsense
we know that it's nonsense because after
all it was funded by the Koch brothers
well how about this there's another
study from the left-wing Urban Institute
they estimated the cost of Medicare for
all here's what they came up with thirty
two trillion dollars over the next ten
years thirty two trillion dollars that
is twice the annual GDP of the United
States it is double the annual federal
budget every single year
it's another four trillion dollars of
federal budget every year and there's a
study from this Marcaida center and they
say it'll cost 300 and it'll cost thirty
two point six trillion dollars over ten
years according to Bloomberg Bernie
Sanders his plan builds on Medicare all
US residents would be covered with no
co-pays and deductibles for medical
services the insurance industry would be
relegated to a minor role Charles Blue
House is the study's author he was a
senior economic advisor to former
President Bush and a public trustee at
Social Security and Medicare during the
Obama administration so this is not a
partisan hack
he says enacting something like Medicare
for all would be a transformative change
in the size of the federal government
we'll talk about a little bit more about
this proposal and why it's going to fail
and why Democrats should be in charge
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wire comso for $9.99 a month
you can get your subscription to daily
wire comm when you do rest of the show
live rustic laven show live Racine
Knowles is show live be part of our
mailbags on Friday and with your annual
subscription comes this the very
greatest and all beverage vessels left
dist here's hot or cold tumbler you will
enjoy it you will love it you will live
it it's incredible so go check it out
$99 a year cheaper than the monthly
subscription also subscribe over at
YouTube and SoundCloud that makes sure
that you are actually updated whenever
we have our Sunday specials for example
last Sunday Mike Rowe stopped by and it
was great to go check that out
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so thirty two point six trillion dollars
how much money is thirty two point six
trillion dollars Tianna low over on
Twitter she says that is nearly twice
our annual GDP it's fifty four times our
annual defense spending it's over eight
times our annual federal budget it's two
hundred and eighty one times the private
sectors annual medical R&D investment it
is eight hundred and sixty seven times
the federal government's annual medical
R&D investment and by the way medicaid
covers one in three Californians and
nearly 40 percent of la residents and
since the ACA expansion medical
providers went from barely breaking even
to making five point four billion
dollars in profits from 2014 to 2016
okay so this is this is ridiculous okay
by the way the statistics I'm citing
about you know is eight hundred sixty
seven times the the federal government
annual medical R&D investment right we
are talking about over ten years but
still it is twice our annual GDP thirty
two point six trillion dollars it's an
enormous blow out in spending now Bernie
Sanders doesn't have any actual argument
with these statistics he just doesn't
like that the Koch brothers funded this
particular study but again the Urban
Institute says it'll cost thirty two
trillion dollars as well it turns out
that covering people's health care
endlessly means that you're going to
spend endless amounts of money that Dan
McLaughlin over at national review he
has a framework for understanding health
care and here's what he says he says
basically you can have three things in
health care you can have affordability
you can have universality you can have
quality you can only have two of those
three things you cannot have all three
again affordability universality quality
they can either be cheap or it can be
Universal everybody can have it or it
can be good so it can be good and it can
be affordable but not everybody's gonna
have it right it's a free market system
you can have universal and cheap but
then it's gonna be kind of crappy you're
gonna have Universal and good but then
it's gonna be really expensive right so
you can only have two of these
particular three things Bernie Sanders
says you can have all three because he
is lying to you I love this Bernie
Sanders his office they say that this
estimate is bad but their office has not
done a cost analysis wait you mean a
lazy socialist who didn't bother doing
his homework I can't believe it
that's crazy Bernie Sanders his staff
did find an error an initial version of
the Mercatus report which counted a long
term care program that was in the twenty
sixteen proposal but not the current one
which means it will merely cost twenty
nine point six trillion dollars as
opposed to thirty two points
trillion dollars oh well that that fixes
everything and by the way you could
remove every dollar from every rich
person in the in the United States it
would not pay for this for more than a
year okay so the this idea that you are
going to somehow fund all of this is
just insane the the study estimated the
doubling all federal individual and
corporate income taxes would not fully
cover the additional costs so all of
this sounds great all this sounds nice
how you gonna pay for it the answer is
you ain't you ain't because Democrats
have no interest in paying for this
stuff if you actually want to help cut
health care costs by the way in the
United States there is a way to do it
well you actually have to do is ease
regulation particularly when it comes to
all of the administrative paperwork
dealing with all the regulation is what
doctors do most of the time you may have
heard my wife is a doctor okay being a
doctor that means she has to deal with
paperwork on a near constant basis and
when you own your own office you have to
deal with with Medicare and Medicaid
many doctors have stopped working with
the government because they don't want
to deal with all the regulations and all
the paperwork in the New York Times has
a piece out just a couple of weeks ago
saying that it only takes a glance at a
hospital bill or at the myriad choices
you may have for health care coverage to
get a sense of the bewildering
complexity of health care financing in
the United States the complexity doesn't
just exact a cognitive cost it comes
with administrative costs in 1999 a New
England Journal of Medicine which is the
premier journal of medicine in the
United States they estimated that about
30 percent of all American healthcare
expenditures were the result of
administration in other words dealing
with insurance companies working with
the government trying to deal with
regulation all that stuff is expensive
and you know it gets charged for it you
do and your insurance company does there
are ways to cut down on that but that
means do you regulation which is
precisely the opposite of what the left
actually wants to do it also turns out
by the way that nationalized health care
systems there's a lot of paperwork as
well this idea that solves everything to
be nationalized is just not true either
so this is what's so ridiculous about
this the Democrats come forward with
their proposals for 2018 this is what
Trump really should be hitting them what
Trump should be saying is you can't
allow these people to be in charge
because if you put these people in
charge it's going to be a disaster
hey their policy proposals are insane
another policy proposal that's just it
just shows how asinine
the left's take on economics is hey
Kamala Harris tweeted this out you tweet
it out under the rent Relief Act anyone
who spends more than 30% of their income
rent would be eligible for a federal tax
credit what would you do with that extra
money in your pocket I want to UM let's
do some basic econ here under the rent
Relief Act anyone who spends more than
30 percent of their income on rent would
be eligible for a federal tax credit
what do you think that money's gonna go
the answer is to the raised rent okay
you'll spend more money on rent these if
I just give you money back because you
spend a lot on rent what do you think
that your landlord is going to do he's
going to raise your rent because there's
now increased demand in the in the
housing market there are people who want
to get into the housing market and spend
more in the housing market and they're
going to offer the landlord more you're
just gonna take that money and you're
now going to spend it on the red
Democrats don't understand basic
economics so they make proposals that
sound like free money but actually are
just inflating the cost of the actual
product itself no Democrat should not be
in charge now
I also want to talk about you know the
the the insipidity of our politics the
stupidity of our politics this is the
best story of the day it's pretty
spectacular so the Democratic challenger
in Virginia's fifth congressional
district
Leslie Cockburn I'm not making that name
up call that her opponent GOP nominee
Denver Riggleman again not making the
name up for his love of Bigfoot erotica
again not making this up
this is real Cockburn posted the claims
on Twitter noting that Riggleman was a
running mate of Corey Stewart who she
called a white supremacist Cockburn
tweeted out my opponent Denver Riggleman
running mate of Corey Stewart was caught
on camera campaigning with a white
supremacist now he's been exposed as a
devotee of Bigfoot erotica this is not
what we need on Capitol Hill now I know
you're sitting there asking yourself
what in the world is Bigfoot erotica
it's exactly what it sounds like it is
erotica about Bigfoot her evidence
included a drawing of a naked Bigfoot
with a large and long censored bar over
the presumptive location of Bigfoot's
privates that Riggleman had posted on
Instagram and she also posted a second
image with Riggleman face pasted on top
of another naked but censored Sasquatch
Riggleman just started his campaign
after being named replace representative
Thomas Garrett on the ballot in a red
leading district in June apparently he's
a craft distillery owner and former Air
Force intelligence offer so he's the
officer he's facing Cockburn who's a
journalist author and first-time
candidate trying to capitalize on
opposition's President Trump in
Charlottesville another liberal on
claves now is it true that any of this
that Riggleman is actually devoted to
Bigfoot erotica of course it's not true
because that's ridiculous there's no
actual such thing as Bigfoot erotica
it's a bunch of people who are mocking
the fact that there should like the idea
of it is so insane
but we now in such live in such a
literalistic universe that somebody puts
up a joke about Bigfoot erotica and
their political opponent decides that it
is absolutely necessary and worthwhile
to turn this into a campaign issue
whether in fact their opponent is
checking out the ding-dong of a creature
that does not exist but wanders around
in the forest so that's very exciting
stuff I'm glad that our politics has has
come this far clearly the founders would
be happy with the state of our republic
Bigfoot erotica just really really solid
stuff well when Democrats are not
worried about fake stories about Bigfoot
erotica they're also worried about
renaming the City of Austin so according
to the Austin Statesman known as both
the father of Texas and the namesake of
the state's capital stephen f austin
carved out the early outlines of texas
among his many accomplishments he also
opposed an attempt by Mexico to ban
slavery in the province of Tejas and
said if slaves were freed they would
turn into vagabonds a nuisance and a
menace for that reason the city of
Austin's equity office suggested
renaming the city in a report about
existing Confederate monuments that was
published this week also on the list of
locales possibly would be renamed Peace
Park the Bouldin Creek neighborhood
barton springs and ten streets named for
William Barton the Daniel Boone of Texas
who is a slave owner so now we are in
the process of renaming all sorts of
things including the City of Austin
itself because Samuel Austin who helped
found the city was a slave owner this is
what we're gonna do now which means that
we're going to have to turn Washington
DC into not Washington DC anymore
because George Washington was a slave
owner as well and we're going to have to
rename the state of Washington - also
we're gonna have to get rid of Jefferson
City we're gonna have to get rid of the
Jefferson Memorial gonna have tear that
sucker down we're gonna have to get rid
of of any reference whatsoever to any
southern president from the first part
of the the nation's history
it'll just be it'll just be great
apparently Austin will do this to virtue
signal so the council has already
renamed robert e lee road and jefferson
davis avenue there they now want to
rename austin now listen i understand
people being uncomfortable it's you lee
black folks being uncomfortable with the
fact that some of these figures were
being paid tribute to
as people who are proponent proposing
slavery I do think there is a difference
in kind by the way between Samuel Austin
and Jefferson Davis I think that
Jefferson Davis is mostly famous for
having defended slavery as the
presidents of the Confederacy I don't
think the same is true of Samuel Austin
who's mostly famous for having started
settlement American settlement in Texas
right what we well we pay attention to
with regard to naming things is
generally the thing that the person is
most famous for but it does demonstrate
the left's full-scale desire to destroy
history and whitewash history why is it
possible that you can't just explain
that people did bad things in the past
and some people who may have been bad
had an impact on the nation's history I
don't understand why any of this is
supremely controversial or difficult
teaching history is all about teaching
nuance but we now live in a world where
every nuance has to be removed forcibly
by the way all the people who are busily
getting rid of the name Austin in Austin
Texas in a hundred years when their
names are on street signs all of them
will be will be cast out too because
virtually all these people are going to
be pro-abortion pro pro pro the
termination of babies and all those
people will have their names remove from
buildings too because in a hundred years
that's gonna be looked on with exactly
the same sort of scorn that we currently
look on slavery so they're gonna have to
get ready for that as well okay let's do
a couple of things that I like and then
we'll do a couple of things that I hate
so a thing that I like so I mentioned
last week that my dad is a tremendous
jazz pianist and I was not kidding
here's a cut of my dad playing this is
him playing jazz girl from Ipanema and
all of this is original you know he made
it up because he's a jazz musician so
here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
so my dad can play so you can check out
some of these cuts he's got a couple of
cuts on YouTube that you can check out
just search David Shapiro piano and and
check it out I will have to have my dad
on the Sunday special one time because I
think that'd be a lot of fun and I know
I'll interview him about all the stuff
my dad was playing clubs when he was
like 12 13 years old he would he would
go into the clubs and play jazz piano at
these clubs so when I when I say that I
grew up with a bit of a musical
background that's because my dad was was
that guy okay time for let's do another
thing that I like so I will admit when
people on the left do something funny so
I people on the Left have no sense of
humor about people on the right they say
that nobody on the right has any sense
of humor we're all a bunch of
fuddy-duddies and when we make a joke
it's not really a joke because we're
mean and we're cruel sometimes the left
has something funny I will acknowledge
that this is actually pretty funny so
the other day some schmuck went to the
Hollywood when town to Hollywood
Boulevard in wrecked Donald's from star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame so Kevin
Spacey star totally okay Harvey
Weinstein's star totally okay but Donald
Trump star completely destroyed by it by
this this idiot on the left by the way
that will have to be paid for by the
actual institution the this Hollywood
institution that actually puts those
stars on the sidewalk
and Donald Trump is not the only
conservative who has a star on those
sidewalks me Ronald Reagan obviously has
one but other than ever friend Larry
elder as one as well in any case I will
admit that this was funny so a couple of
lefties went down to the star and they
guarded the star dressed up as Russian
soldiers and like the full-on gear which
is it with the Russian flag which is
kind of funny so here is Kimmel talking
about it security out there on the
boulevard protecting his star
[Applause]
anyway that's natural combat
okay so I will acknowledge that that is
pretty funny okay that like eat credit
where credit is due sometimes people on
the Left can be funny okay time for a
thing that I hate gender roles for
children are important gender is
connected with biology why is it that
primates like chimpanzees hey males and
females act differently and have
different genders is that because of the
patriarchy the monkey patriarchy was it
because of that
well apparently according to the BBC the
answer is yes according to the BBC all
gender is connected with social
stereotyping and so what they're going
to do is torture a few kids to make sure
that you know that you are actually a
sexist so they cut a video over at BBC
I'm sure taxpayers in Britain are super
thrilled that this is what they spend
time on here is here's the BBC reporting
on taking a couple of kids one who's a
boy and one is a girl and switching
their clothing and then watching as
adults treat them differently right
because adults are not stupid enough to
believe that boys and girls are the same
[Music]
this is Edward who's dressed as a girl
actually that Sophie is Edward ah not
change anything I maybe thought oh this
is a little girl so I have to give a
little girl things fellow men hugely
dominant career as prising maths spatial
awareness our boys learn better at these
or is it nature or is it nurture
the answer is it's not if I tell you
that he is actually a girl really yes oh
I like I like the ladies look of
disapproval like why would you do
suppose it's because of the stereotype
and then that changed your behavior
child it's it and your behavior was
quite directive surprise sale
automatically win for their the pink
pink fluffy toys as soon as the girls
though so it also stereotyping okay this
is so stupid
this is so stupid stop for a second case
stop this is so stupid oh I wish I would
I thought it was more open-minded I
immediately went for the gender
stereotype toy you know why because
babies I have a girl I have a boy you
know what they prefer different toys
they prefer different toys my boy
prefers a lightsaber and smacking his
sister with it my girl prefers actually
sitting there and reading books and
playing with
okay every so often chill grab the sword
and smack a brother back but that's not
because but that's not because she
prefers that kind of toys there's such
there's deep social science about toy
preference okay it's so funny that they
I think it was Hasbro at one point tried
a gender-neutral dollhouse they tried a
gender-neutral dollhouse and you know
what they found what they actually found
is that the girls we're taking the
dollies and putting them to sleep
they're real nice to the little dollies
and the boys we're taking dollies and
catapulting them off the roof of the toy
house because boys and girls are
different the only reason my boy ever
wants to play with anything that my
daughter has is because my daughter has
it
that's legitimately the only reason now
is it bad to reinforce these natural
inclinations of children no would be the
worst thing in the world my kid want to
play with a doll my boy no why would I
possibly like try and steer him in the
direction of playing with dolls when
that's not something he wants number one
and number two when I think it is very
important to reinforce gender
stereotyping I think some gender
stereotyping is quite good not about
what you can do and what you can't my
daughter can be a scientist my daughter
can be a doctor her mommy is but it is
important to recognize that men and
women are not the same and trying to
undermine this by confusing a child is
the stupidest thing I've ever seen
but I'm sure it makes you feel better
about yourself to believe that you have
this much control over the world but you
actually don't it turns out that men and
women are very different in a variety of
ways that extend beyond genitals and the
fact that the left continues to propose
this anti scientific nonsense that boys
and girls are completely the same and
that if we just retrain woman's who'd be
more interested in engineering that
suddenly the gap would disappear it's
just not true it's just not true you
know they've been trying this stuff in
the Nordic countries and it's been
failing dramatically there's no evidence
that any of it works because in the end
nature will end up winning it's it's
it's all it's ridiculous and to do this
to small children to dress up a boy as a
little girl just so you can show parents
oh my gosh look at your look at your
stereotyping why don't you just dress
the boy in boy clothes because he's a
boy it's important it's important now
it's interesting people have this whole
thing now about cross-dressing well why
do you care if your boy wears a dress
why do you care if your doctor wears a
white coat why do you care if your
police officer wears a police uniform
why do you care if you walk into the
office dressed like a normal human being
or dressed as a schlub it turns out that
clothes actually means something to give
off social cues and not only do they
give off social cues they all
so give you a uniform to identify with
it is good that boys should identify
with other boys it is good that girls
should identify with other girls it is
good that sexes understand the
differences between the sexes and it is
not bad to reinforce those things again
this is not nothing to do with
reinforcing lies about the capacity of
women or anything of that sort
but - but to suggest that it's good if a
girl cross dresses or a boy cross dress
it makes them more sensitive know it
makes them more confused
they give social cues to people they
should treat the boy as a girl and boys
and girls are not exactly the same in
treating them exactly the same you're a
bad parents if you do if I treated my
girl these act away I the same way I did
the boy you know and I'd be a garbage
parent because they don't want the same
things they're not interested in the
same things and it would be me being me
me being selfishly stupid to do that
turning everybody into these faceless
widgets is the dumbest nonsense ever all
these individualistic lefties who want
to turn babies into widgets they can
treat them all as genderless Neutron
genderless neutral beings and they're
not like the they're not these balls of
slime that you can mold into any shape
you want
yeah idiots okay well we will be back
here tomorrow with much much more
frustration and anger we'll see you then
i'm ben shapiro this is a venture puro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018